we've been talking quite a bit about the
sinclair media story and their control
over so-called local news stations and i
recently wrote an article for pluralist
about this and i wanted to discuss the
article with you and I hope you'll also
read it we're going to be linking to it
in the description to the YouTube clip
for this story and I'm really excited
actually to be working with pluralist
it's a new platform for political
discussion and they explore all sorts of
ideas and culture and politics and I'm
excited to be writing on their website
and my first article with them tackled
this issue of Sinclair media and Michael
Copps who's a former FCC Chairman who
was appointed by George W Bush he's
calling Sinclair Broadcast Group quote
the most dangerous company most people
have never heard of and among people who
follow the news the Sinclair Broadcast
Group name has almost become a household
name because of this viral story and as
a company they've accumulated a hundred
and seventy two local news channels they
now sort of rival Fox News in terms of
growing ubiquity as well as in pro-trump
programming right they have a decidedly
pro-trump
pseudo right-wing bias to the extent
that Trump is a right winger and
Sinclair is also now in the process of
acquiring Tribune media for a ton of
money that would place it's right wing
message in seventy two percent almost
three-quarters of American households as
we recently mentioned on the program and
the political slant of Sinclair wasn't
ever really a secret right before
Trump's inauguration Jared Kushner
actually bragged that during the
election he was able to quote strike a
deal with Sinclair promising Sinclair
access to the campaign and an exchange
Sinclair owned stations would provide
favorable coverage of Donald Trump and
in 2016
Sinclair whose channels again are in
predominantly swing states released
fifteen quote exclusive interviews with
Donald Trump and none with Hillary
Clinton
and now what has pushed thus in Clint
Clint Sinclair story viral is these must
run packages right that are as the name
suggests they must be run on every
single one of Sinclair's affiliates or
at least the one Sinclair determines
need to run it and very often these
segments are nothing but a regurgitation
of conservative talking points filled
with Trump era cliches like snow flake
and fake news but I actually am making
the case that the problem is way deeper
than propaganda and the political bias
of the content towards Trump and skewed
towards the right the entire
infrastructure is a systemic problem
because it completely undermines the
purpose of local news when Sinclair
sends out these mandatory political
content packages and they force-feed the
national discussion into so-called local
news they are basically saying well it
looks like local news but it's really
not local news and the reason that
that's an acute problem is that
Americans believe that their local news
is more trustworthy than national news
and the reason why is obvious right we
think locally we live mostly locally and
so we're predisposed to believe that the
material we get from our local anchors
is more authentic more relevant to our
community than the national stuff and to
a degree it's true or at least in theory
it's true so when people don't realize
that their local news is carefully
crafted propaganda from this national
company Sinclair is able to exploit the
faith that many news consumers have in
their supposed local media when they're
actually just selling us an
assembly-line right-wing message and
this is hugely destructive because in
the not so long run it's going to mean
the demise of regional diversity on
television and even local TV is going to
look identical across the country more
than it already does in that format
which I've actually talked about before
and I recently read a defense of
Sinclair's practices because you
can always find someone willing to
defend just about any practice david har
say ani said that sinclair is doing
quote advocacy journalism and that
that's valuable and that it's good to
have competing biases in society so that
all views are heard and can be
challenged or something along those
lines and sure I mean in principle he's
right we want a marketplace of ideas and
we can evaluate ideas and decide what
makes sense and what should prevail but
the problem isn't that a biased media
company is being biased it's the lack of
transparency it's the bamboozling of
viewers that's happening when Sinclair
monopolizes local markets and people
don't even understand what it is that
they're seeing and I've explained before
I've been talking for years that one of
the despicable things that Fox News does
is they blur the lines between what's
news and what's opinion journalism and
you wonder as you watch am i watching a
report right now or am i watching a
commentary and it's by design that you
often can't tell or that fox news mixes
them together and Sinclair is doing
another version of that am i watching
local news or am i watching force fed
national talking points produced by
someone who's cozy with the president
and struck a deal with Jared Kushner
packaged to be delivered by my local
anchors who I think have my community
sort of as their priority so what can be
done about this I genuinely have no idea
I mentioned that Sinclair is looking to
buy Tribune media that's currently being
considered by the FCC we can't really
count on the current administration's
FCC to stop it we've got FCC chairman
and Trump appointee Ajit PI being
investigated by his own agency and yet
still the odds are in Sinclair's favor
that the FCC is not going to get in the
way of the purchase of Tribune media so
if there is a hope it's going to be
found far from corporate media and the
silver lining is that the Internet has
plenty of independent journalists and
news outlets and yes I am one of those
and certainly this is a circumstance
where
I stand to gain but we also all stand to
gain from more diversity and voices we
need to be supporting other models of
funding that enabled the audience to
actually find and decide what are the
voices and messages that actually
reflect their beliefs or their ideals
and cater to their interests and values
and morals and and the real silver
lining here is that which is that
hopefully the Sinclair media scandal
wakes people up to the reality that
you've got to support independent media
when so-called local news stations are
increase increasingly owned and managed
either by the big news networks or by
media conglomerates like Sinclair we
need to look elsewhere and that's why
we're working to expand the show and
doing all of the other things that you
know that we are doing send me your
thoughts about my commentary and article
on Sinclair it's on pluralist we're
linking to the article in the video
description for the youtube clip for
this story the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership